Vào mừng giá vòng mến SSA tăng mạnh 2,5% đến 2,5% đồng mỗi lượng,
lên mức cao kỳ lục 1,5% xấu phê bún trực đồng.
Công ti vàng bạc đã quý sây gòn SJC,
nghiêm ít giá vòng mến SSA ở mức 1,5% vệ chính,
đến 1,5% xấu phê bún trực đồng mỗi lượng,
1 vào mắn ra, 2 trực tăng trăm ngàn đồng ở chiều 1 vào,
và tăng 2 chiều 3 trong ngàn đồng ở chiều bắn ra,
sau với giá trước phía nè hôm qua mười ba tháng mười.
Công ra tăng mạnh giá vòng nhấn trần xấu phía bảo biến mink châu,
quan mức 1,5% vệ chính, đến 1,5% vệ chính trực đồng mỗi lượng,
1 vào mắn ra, 2 trực tính chăm ngàn đồng mỗi lượng,
ở cả 2 chiều 1 vào, mắn ra sau với giá trước phía nè hôm qua.
Trong khi đó, tại công ty cộvân tập đàn vàng bạc đã quý đôi gí,
nhấn trần xấu phía quán mức 1,5% đến 1,5% vệ nắm,
đến 1,5% vệ nắm trực đồng mỗi lượng, 1 vào bắn ra,
còn tại công ty cộvân đồng tư phạm phu quyết,
sau dịch phạm gián ở mức 1,5% đến 1,5% vệ nắm vệ nắm vệ nắm trực đồng mỗi lượng, 1 vào bắn ra.